hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm your host Mike McCarty
here with Miguel concepción from
GameSpot as well and Joel Simon of
Nintendo treehouse hi what are we here
to play today so we're here to show off
pokken tournament deluxe which is the
deluxe version of the Wii U version that
was released last year and a pokken
tournament hat features five new
characters there's a dark rye and Poli
on scizor and Croagunk and those were
characters that were in the Japanese
arcade version okay and now they've been
released for this switch version that's
coming out November 22nd they've also
added an exclusive character to the
Nintendo switch version which is a
decidua into situation from Pokemon Sun
and Pokemon moon okay cool so right now
we're going to show off some of the
features of the of the new switch
version one of the things they've added
is new support pair which is Pope Leo
and and Litton and the support Pokemon
are there to kind of help you as you're
going through a battle the the support
Pokemon will either attack outright
attack your opponent or they will debuff
your opponent and disrupt them or
they'll either increase your abilities
so some of the things they've added to
this new version is that they've added
switch functionality which it's giving
you the ability to to play at home or
you can undock it and play on the go
like at a park bench or whatnot go over
to a friend's house and play Nintendo
switch there over local wireless or if
you if your friend doesn't have a switch
also you can play right there on
tabletop mode with two joint cons and
the switch itself cool yeah we've got a
Daniel and Sarah also from treehouse to
playing it live right now so anybody
watching home this is a yabba playing
right now yeah
oh so one of the one of the things about
pokken tournament that's a little bit
different than your usual fighting game
is it switches between a 3d arena
fighter where you can maneuver around
your opponent and kind of harass them in
a skirmish mode and then it switches
into a dual phase which is more like
your classic 2d fighter and that's where
you can really mix it up throw those hey
Lakers and
and do the big damage so you can switch
in between those two different modes and
that's kind of one of the strategies
between it one of the good things is
Sarah here let's played the CID you I
just activated Papa Leo and Papa Leo is
a support pokemon that enhances your
fighter and what it did was it gives you
the ability to actually double jump more
than your single jump that you have
before okay and Danny just unleashed lit
in there that does damage too okay so as
you see as you're battling through there
there's a it's a simple game to pick up
it's a lot like Smash Brothers where all
the moves are either a direction in a
button share or in a button press and
it's totally contextual to so certain
directions and button presses will do
different things in field mode or field
phase as will they do in and duel things
cool yeah it seems like like you said
smash is good comparison because you
know it's accessible but it's still like
once you actually get into it there's a
lot of depth to it right there is there
is a lot of depth to it I with the
support pokemon and then also dealing
with it has kind of Pokemon elements
that you're used to so characters will
they'll debuff your your opponent
they'll lower their lower their attack
and defense you can see here scissor
just did its synergy burst attacks so
there's a synergy burst mode where kind
of it's like a Super Saiyan mode where
the Pokemon gets powered up and when
you're in that mode you get an attack
chance to attack it with a burst attack
you only get one chance to do it and if
you land that attack you'll be able to
to do massive damage to your opponent
but you only get one chance to do it so
if you were able to block that then
you've got the advantage
and here's deciduous burst burst attack
here that's awesome
yeah one of the cool things is it's kind
of a mix between mega evolutions and
from Pokemon X&Y and then the Z moves
that they had in Pokemon Sun and Moon
right yeah I'm curious how you know
outside of the 5 new characters ok I'm
curious how going to the switch as
opposed to Wii U in terms of just like
you overall feel of the game visit
affect it much like say I played it on
the Wii U a lot yeah the look feel very
different it'll be it'll be they brought
it more in line with the arcade version
so there's it's running at 60 frames a
second it does run at 30 frames a second
in local Wireless just because of the
local Wireless mode but if you're
playing online that 60 frames TV mode or
in tabletop mode yeah and so they
brought it in line with the with the
Japanese versions of Japanese arcade
version which will make a lot of fans
super happy about some other cool things
that they've added to that is they've
added daily missions where if you play
per day they'll give you an objective if
you complete that objective then you
you'll get some extra coins that you
cannot you can get new uniform or new
costume pieces for your avatar I've also
added a team battle mode which is a lot
like the core series game in this where
you pick a team of three fighters and
your opponent picks a team of three
fighters and then it's the last man
standing okay so one thing we have
available here is your shadow Mewtwo one
of the great things is shadow Mewtwo is
available right out of right out of the
box okay so as soon as you start playing
the game all five new characters are
available in shadow Mewtwo is available
to you for the Wii U version shadow
Mewtwo is only available with an amiibo
card or after you beat the game you
would unlock him and now he's completely
on okay so we're looking at Empoleon now
who's also new yeah Empoleon is one of
the new fighters how would you how would
you describe is like is the fighting
style for Empoleon yeah
in Poli on is is more of a bruiser he
wants to get in and mix it up okay
he does have some range attacks too if
so if your infield face you can use this
ice beam to to really freeze the people
and then freeze your opponent and then
get in and so each each of the fighters
is a little bit different shadow shadow
Mewtwo here is about to do his his
synergy burst which is which is pretty
powerful yeah once you get the POE play
out there in and each each pokemon
fighter is a little bit different so
like Empoleon has a little more hit
points so he's more of a bruiser mix it
up in
dual phase there's Croagunk is more of a
speed kind of shifty character more like
ninja and then there's there's more
standard guys like like the sid you i is
more standard well-rounded has a very
good aerial game but that's what you
expect for like an owl right I'll like
Pokemon you mentioned mu2 being a
previously amiibo character is can you
say anything about the amiibo
functionality so there it's limited
Meebo functionality if you do use
amiibos you'll be able to get more
exclusive costume content for your
avatars so if you look up in the corner
that's your avatar you start out as a
kind of basic and as you go through
you'll earn money and unlock different
costume outfits that you can use to to
kind of pimp out your avatar you can get
like a wetsuit and and goggles or you
can get a graduation gallon and cap
there's all kinds of kind of crazy crazy
outfits that you can use and that's
mostly for the online mode it's
interesting to see how like the way you
were just describing the different
fighting styles of the different Pokemon
it's interesting to see how like you
know like playing the other games my
knowledge from that seems like they're
designed with that in mind like their
abilities in the other games right like
that kind of transfers over to their
style in this game yeah one one of the
things like I said Empoleon has ice beam
shadow Mewtwo does have a hyper beam
that it unleashes okay and then there's
there's other characters like program
will use venom shock and one of the
great things about this game is each
each Pokemon has kind of a different
mode that you go in one of the dark dark
ride characters has a nightmare mode
where if you land a specific move that
will power up your other moves and then
they'll do different things on top of
that scissor has a sword dance where if
you're able to sit back and somebody
lets you sit back if you're scissor you
can get the sword dance out there and
then your moves become more powerful so
there's there's little hints and
elements of the core series games that
are in this but it's in full like 3d
rendered grab right cool you have
interesting idea I didn't play much
poking on the Wii U like as much as I
would like to
so now that you know like I feel like
the switch like immediately right out of
the gate was such a great launch I feel
like maybe like this is a great chance
to bring you know obviously more people
into this oh yes yeah and the the switch
platform makes it a lot more accessible
to more people right so you don't you
don't need to have your system at home
with the Wii U now you can undock and go
over to a friend's house use the to joy
Khan's and then and then play with that
play with them on tabletop mode so it
makes it a lot more accessible for
everybody to play and just mix it up
cool did you see this release of the
deluxe version as an opportunity to do
to retool or balance any any aspects of
the yeah yeah that that's one of the
things that the community for the Wii
version were a little disappointed with
is that there was no way to balance the
fighters because the Japanese arcade
version did do some balancing with the
characters to kind of make them all in
the same playing field a level playing
field and now the switch version does
bring it in line with that Japanese
arcade version yeah so which will make a
lot of people happy
have you played much I like on the joy
count I imagine I'm like you know
obviously I think I myself would prefer
the pro controller but have you played
much of the joy Khan is there an ideal
way to play this the pro pro controller
is really good also this does support
the Hori controller that was released
for the Wii U version okay so they had a
pokken exclusive 4e controller that you
can use and people have been playing it
on the show floor and they really like
it pro controller is really nice the joy
cons really do a good job too especially
if you have the wrist strap on there so
you have those left and right buttons
for blocking and support right there
yeah like you were saying earlier with
the controls kinda like a smash controls
direction plus a button that seems like
it's you know it's not like a like a
Mortal Kombat game or anything were you
doing a lot of analog input and national
things like that yeah yeah so it does
make it a little bit more accessible to
your your everyday gamer sure but there
is there is a lot of there is frame
counting in the
where you can really get down to to the
nitty-gritty imagine it must've been
difficult and you know like Nintendo sat
down to figure out how to please both
fighting game fans and Pokemon fans who
say this game is geared more toward one
camp or the other it's not it's
accessible for for both camps it was
developed by Namco Bandai sure so they
they're familiar and that's where it
gets it spoken name from yeah and of the
Tekken series so it does have that that
fighting bones to its skeleton sure with
the framework of Pokemon around it too
and so there's is something for
everybody right yeah really is and then
I correct me if I'm wrong but there
would be like a 3v3 yeah that's the team
battle that's it seem battle word if you
have if you have you pick a team of
three Pokemon and your opponent picks a
team of three Pokemon and then they
battle it out Last Man Standing okay
yeah I battled against my coworker when
we first got this out and he went
through my entire crew until he had like
what his first fighter had a sliver of
health but I couldn't oh yeah yeah it
I'm imagine like figuring out your team
composition to like counter the others
like yeah super important yeah because
there is there is some some guys that
are faster Croagunk is a faster fighter
but a little lower hip points
Blaziken here is a little it's more
well-rounded then there's also Pokemon
that are more technical and that's a
dark rye and Gengar which are there more
shifty and hard to get a hold of okay
and so depending on your fighting style
its if you can you can change it up and
switch it up if you're just starting out
I recommend some of the the basic
fighters like Pikachu is well-rounded
doesn't look like he stand up against
Charizard but he does a really good job
on his own that play sickens another one
that's a fan favorite and then also
Mewtwo is also a really good fighter
also yeah
Blaziken was my my choice when I played
at X&Y
yeah he's tough because he has he does
have some ranged attack but when he does
get into your face you can really mix it
and do some damage so one thing you
notice that Chevron's above blaziken's
head that's signifies that he got
powered up so his defense and his attack
gets powered up okay so there's a lot
like the the core series game to where
you can can add to you can add to your
abilities or debuff your opponents right
abilities also yeah yeah I'm super
interested to see like um I don't know
Miguel did you get the chance to play
much on wiiu a little bit yeah yeah um
do you play did you play many other
fighting games uh I mean I could see
traces of Tekken in this sure um the one
thing I was really curious is how you
you have any idea how the studio settled
on this roster no we don't we don't have
any well I haven't seen any input on it
and how it was was decided but um some
some of the choices or like Croagunk
seems a little strange because he's a
lot smaller than the other opponents or
like Pikachu Libre but is Pikachu Libre
is a little bit different than when
you're normal Pikachu
yeah he he's got more wrestling moves I
do like it's the diversity of character
here you can sort of like have these
classic very familiar Pokemon characters
and yeah mix it up with some of the
newer ones yeah that's one that
everybody knows you two and Pikachu and
and of course the Charizard and then
there's some other other Pokemon too
Darkrai is also a fan favorite too
yeah yeah yeah it's also interesting
like like you touched on I like Pikachu
I wouldn't immediately think of like a
fighting game character Blake him
obviously seems tailor-made to it but
it's interesting to see how you
implement those abilities with someone
like Pikachu yeah yeah well Pikachu's a
really good fighter because you can
attack you from afar with this lightning
bolt and thunder shock and that kind of
share and then getting close into Iron
Tail and all these other moves that
you've seen it in the in the core series
games but now you can see them in a plan
of fighting hunger that's really cool to
see awesome well Jill Simon
unfortunately we do have to wrap up
Daniel and Sarah thank you so much for
playing off stage but uh all right final
question when can we get our hands on
this Oh
September 22nd but when it comes up
awesome that's actually my birthday so I
will pick us up for myself
awesome I'm looking forward to it but
again
you so much for coming up always
appreciate having a Nintendo on the
stage and we will be back soon with a
we're going to look at Gran Turismo
sport but of course you can
in the meantime catch up on demos and
developer interviews throughout the week
we'll see in a little bit